ladies and gentlemen it's time for a
game show that is sweeping the nation
like a deadly virus
it's you're partying for what now
and now please welcome your host terry
davis
thanks derek i'm tarik the host of
you partying for what now a game show
that sees you're still partying in month
10 of a dangerous global pandemic and
asks
what's that about today on the show we
were supposed to have three contestants
but
wanda and evan both called out sick
because of coronavirus
classic so let's welcome our only
contestant
i'm so amber for this i moved so many
things around to be here
what things oh you know just lunches and
get-togethers and stuff
over zoom right
you're not gonna do very well at this
the game is simple amber
we polled a hundred disease experts and
hospital workers for responses
to a simple question all you have to do
is answer ready
i am all right the question is
amber you partying for what now
top 10 answers on the board there's only
one answer on the board
that's right they unanimously agreed
that there's only one good answer as to
why you'd be partying in a pandemic
okay easy a wedding
nope a wedding can be postponed or in a
worst case scenario done
over zoom what about a christmas party
granny didn't put covet on the wish list
and if she did you know she just
returned it for store credit
what if it's my friend's birthday party
sister's birthday party
mother's birthday party niece's birthday
party
but she only turns three once and if you
all get together
pop-pop may not see her turn four okay
well
what if it's my little cousin's
graduation and everybody at the party
agrees to stand
six feet away from each other the entire
time how many people are gonna be there
just his little family and his little
friends so if all of them had to make
sure they stayed six feet apart
how big of a venue would you need as
big as the astrodome yeah that's right
yeah okay well
what if my sister was kidnapped in some
sort of liam neeson taken scenario
and i had hacked into one of the
kidnappers facebooks
and learned that they were going to a
party oh so you're going to the party to
fight them you're gonna fight
them a bunch of kidnappers you are
you're gonna fight them
do one push-up right now i would but
um it's not the right kind of floor and
i would need different shoe
i just ate a big lunch um no
a taken scenario is not a good excuse
for going to a party right now
can i use a lifeline or something sure
if you like you can call wanda or
evan and ask them to answer for you no i
can't they're at a housewarming party
oh a housewarming party no
two people with covet should definitely
not be at a housewarming party right now
okay then i give up if there's only one
good reason for going to a party during
a pandemic i don't know what it is
fair enough show us the answer
it says psych there ain't one damn
reason for you to be at a party right
now
we've been struggling with this [ __ ] for
10 months now and you still haven't
gotten it into your heads
people are dying 433
000 people have died los angeles alone
has a million cases this thing is
serious
i know i know you're sick of being
inside all the time
but this is only going to keep going
longer if you fools don't wise up
and act right stop hanging out with
people i
want to go to the movie theater if i
don't get to see the new batman or
whatever is in the movie theater i'm
going to be so mad at y'all
i will absolutely start busting heads on
god
wow all 100 experts said that
everyone verbatim
[Music]
you